the fourth season of Bill Birds animated
Netflix series f is for family he's got
Laura Dern in there Justin Long Sam
Rockwell it started up last week he's
also in the Judd Apatow film the king of
Staten Island starring bill alongside
Pete Davidson and Marisa Tomei that
premiered on June 12th big-time actor
now no longer comedian big-time actor
Billy burr good morning bill I don't
know about that but yes I got a hit some
lines in a movie that wasn't mine that's
a Pete Davidson vehicle Dan I you borrow
it I don't know if you steal the movie
but you borrowed the movie is that fair
to say I I don't know you did well it
was fun thank you yeah and and Marisa
Tomei brightens up everybody's day she's
probably the best I've ever worked with
she was just was incredible to work
opposite against and and like I don't
know I don't know how to quite put into
words like she was well as people she
put the glasses on and they had the wig
that she wasn't she just became somebody
else which was very intimidating I was
like my god I just a stupid comic how am
I gonna hang in here with this but uh
yep she was she was amazing but how do
you work on the make out scenes you
don't
radio loves it all the creeps are in
radio what was that like did you feel
feelings believe it or not I had never
done a kiss see kissing scene in any
acting other than like kisses somebody
hello real quick when you came home so
you know and it's funny is nobody you
just assumed that you know what you're
doing so I just remember before we did
the first one she was just she just
looked at judge she goes is this like a
kiss kiss or was this like and he goes
oh you know you're you're you're totally
head over heels above it was just so
like mechanical that it just felt like
it was part of the job which so that's
what it was and then not to mention like
you know way we were shooting we were in
clothes so the people like
who lived in the house next door who
weren't in the movie we're all sitting
on their stairs and looking at it so it
was probably the least romantic thing
ever so you're you know you're in your
head oh my god you know it's my breath
steak is this gonna look bad at Bala by
its it's nothing nothing like what you
think and the reason why I bring it up I
wasn't being creepy because I was in a
Sandler movie where I have to kiss a
woman and I'm not script it's not
scripted to kiss her Sandler decides to
throw it into the script and and it was
awkward I didn't know the woman and I
had no time to think about it and then
you kiss her and then I was like oh god
hopefully I don't have to do another
take like it was uncomfortable that's
exactly what I thought and I remember
when I got through that I was like all
right this movie's all downhill from
here
you know I got to do that they somehow
liked what I did and now I can kind of
continue on so I actually you know a lot
of being a comedian people who say oh my
god I can't believe you do that how do
you get the nerve to go up there I find
acting is takes way more courage because
like we stand up I mean there is the
initial the first time they call you up
there and you hang on for dear life but
you have like an act and you you control
the areas that you're gonna go to so you
will is you will create a comfort zone
up there that you can just stay in for
your whole career if you want but like
you get into acting it's like to have
you know you look at the page going I
don't know how to do I got a dance you
know opposite Mark Wahlberg or somebody
to doing something I was like it's just
like we wrote this you hire do you have
to do it where is a comedian I could be
like no I'm not doing that That's not me
that's not part of my brand like was
with acting it's like we wrote this you
have to go do it and also when they see
your performance and I've seen some of
the reactions it's like oh wow he can be
a serious actor and I I remind people
and I said this after i swatched the
movie if you think of comedy there's a
lot of darkness to comedy because you
live things in your life you just
illuminate them to make jokes of what
happened that could be something bad you
know Sandler doing uncut gems they're
like Manny
be a serious actor I'm assuming as a
comedian you're kind of digging deep
into dark areas there with your family
and then you make fun of it so you are
acting that way if you listen to a lot
of stories that comics tell what they're
telling you is is very what happened in
the life was very dramatic and they
lived the drama of it and then telling
the story afterwards is just like
putting the fly god geez you wouldn't
listen you wouldn't believe this day but
like where's what whatever they're
joking about when it was happening it
wasn't funny to them so you know it's I
don't I don't know it's also kind of
funny to me that you would think that
somebody could actually live a
drama-free life like nothing bad was
gonna happen you have no disagreements
just walking around with like a red nose
and a clown horn not what it is but you
know what it's like however people see
you then that that's the perception I
mean before I became a comedian I
thought comedians were the coolest
people in the world that all they did
was just go around joking around all day
making you laugh every eight seconds you
know that thing that a lot of people in
the club the crowd do when they come up
to you like wow you're like really
mellow wow you're not like how it's like
do you think I was gonna be that guy
screaming around and jumping up and down
like how long would that be interesting
when I had Judd Apatow in last week I
said can you guys the reason why
comedians hang out with comedians is you
probably don't suffer fools then and if
you're with like you know Jimmy next
door he's gonna try too hard to make you
laugh so does that white comedians hang
out with each other well I think just
juxtaposition where we are we probably
you know you get to know your co-workers
you hang out with them and stuff and my
thing as long as somebody's cool or
whatever like I can hang out with them
and I know that I don't want to sit
around and talk about my job after I'm
done doing it the same way a plumber I
don't want to sit there and be like so
like where do you get a busted radiator
well if he doesn't want to sit there and
talk about that so I usually whoever I
hang out with I try to they're into
sports that's what's great about sports
as you can steer it you know I remember
the first time I did your show we went
to a break and I brought up some sports
analogy or something like that
just looked over me and you would like
these are the thoughts that consume your
world I was like oh my god I just did
that what is the last thing - Oh more
sports and I did it we're all guilty of
it I know but people will do that
they'll go and here let me give you a
sports analogy that like I couldn't
understand something unless there's a
sports analogy that they have to dumb it
down for me to go oh okay now I get it
yeah I wanted your approval that I was
officially a sports fan would even the
comedian's people want your approval I
guess that they're funny or uh you know
but I don't know I find most part people
are pretty cool we're talking to bill
burr the movie is the king of Staten
Island and Pete Davidson it's a Judd
Apatow film also f is for family at
stars bill and Laura Dern the fourth
season of the animated Netflix series
what sport are you missing the most
right now uh that's a tough one I would
say the last two months was was playoff
hockey yeah and I just kind of like I'm
more in like just baseball I guess I get
I miss baseball I got excited to see
some stuff about the NFL I mean I don't
know how this works when you know you
have a pandemic and that the fire isn't
put out yet and then they are I wake
we're gonna go out now and get the fire
going again I'd be honestly I don't
understand why we have all this money to
bail out banks but we don't have a an
additional fund to just get everybody
tested you know who has it you know who
doesn't whoever has it stays home and
everybody else can go to work so they
don't lose their house or their business
you would think I mean I know it's a
behemoth trying to run a country I said
that like I've ever done it but you know
you know I know it's not that simple but
I hope we're gonna I heard New York is
getting tested is getting a lot easier
which was the first positive news I've
heard in a while so hopefully I don't
know
I just don't want to see people go broke
why don't you stick to the jokes here
bill honking hey I get over my do you
remember what was it well I don't know
if it was
intimidating maybe that's not the right
word but when you're on with Chappell
when you're on that that show or you're
on Breaking Bad like the magnitude of
that and maybe they're not the same but
what were those feelings like when you
were working you know on those those two
shows oh the night before in the in the
van ride over to set yeah terrified like
how do i yeah you never feel at least I
don't feel worthy of being there and but
then I got this German Irish thing where
I can just wall off all of my feelings
which is bad in my personal life but in
my professional life it's good like I
dislike a place I can go to mentally
that I just like all right I'm just you
know one foot in front of the other I'm
just gonna do this scene people want you
to you know they want it to go well and
then it's like afterwards like the level
of relief that I have you know after if
I would do stand-up on Letterman and it
went well just the level of relief I
would get so wound up emotionally and
then right before I go out there I would
I had this little mental game I could
play to get myself out of that you know
I used to do the thing I would I would
walk by the crowd and really look at the
crowd as they were lined up waiting to
go into the Ed Sullivan Theater you know
look at that guy with his I Love New
York t-shirt these are just regular
people bill this is just like doing a
spot at the cellar
it's just Dave Letterman is gonna be
sitting you know five feet away from you
so yeah I don't know if you measure
yourself with like Chappell and his
brilliance and you know can you be on
that level or you're gonna be on break
oh that's very easy Davis Davis Dave and
then the rest of us are doing stand-up I
mean his ladies special is incredible
yeah well you just you know you look at
some great team I'm gonna do a sports
analogy okay good not not for you this
is how I live my life okay good okay on
all sports teams there is there is the
Tom Brady Joe Montana guy but then you
know then there's also like the the guys
who just like just step up and make a
play
come Butler this those guys they step up
in the moment and then like you just
look like okay I'm just gonna do my job
my job is to you know do this these
little five lines I got these five lines
down Dave Chappelle's carrying the
weight of this or bryan cranston yeah i
find you just do your job and get in
then when they say cut you get the know
that you get it you get out of the way
sorry about that
huh that's bill burr comedian joining us
on the program you got to do something
with the background there in your crib
I don't yeah you do I don't yeah you're
like a 17 year old chick who's
accessorizing too much I can barely see
you
you got dolls you're the placeless in a
nose ring do you want why don't you send
me half of that crap but we'll meet in
the middle
give bars on your window there what kind
of neighborhood you live
oh they're curtain all they look like
bars you want to go yeah let's go around
the room here
well you're still like I got sucked up
for Breaking Bad fans I usually don't
save souvenirs but this shirt was so
ridiculous I just have this laying here
this is the shirt the stagecoach shirt
whatever the cowboy shirt that I wore
when we robbed the Train why don't you
get it framed I haven't got around to it
all right
what else do you have in there and that
was like seven years ago or whatever
right all right let's show you what else
do you got here I'll show you the
coolest thing any any fan ever got me
okay
all right so I did a Gigan in Boston I'm
a huge hockey fan and this guy who
custom paints goalie mask sweatshirt
look at this bird oh it says burner in
rouen B yeah and on this side it's got
look at that it's got George Carlin
Richard Pryor on this side I play drums
as a hobby saliste and big band days
they would say er like Buddy Rich Led
Zeppelin cuz I like John Bonham and
Steven Adler skull from the Appetite for
Destruction
[Laughter]
and then on top I'm a Ford guy I also
say go you know what yourself at the end
of my podcast so the f-word is written
like the Ford logo can't have that and
on the back he's got a Patrice O'Neal
the greatest comment below isn't that
incredible that is awesome and he just
gave it to me and look I could barely
thank him and he left who's over your
right shoulder that that's Angus Young
that's Angus Young on the high voltage
tour that's Bobby Orr and down there
that's at the Comedy Store
Norma Donald and David Spade three of my
huge comedy heroes that was my favorite
cast of SNL and one night we were all
down there I think it was David Spade
show and he put me on in the main room
Comedy Store back when you could do
stand-up comedy in front of human beings
and you know we went down there just it
just so happened that there was a
photographer down there and he snapped
that picture and that is my my favorite
like you know I other than my close
friends that I started with I just if
you told me that was gonna get to work
with any of them in any capacity I I
would have been you know over the moon
don't get sentimental I mean once again
stick to the jokes here bill you're
getting heavy
can you stop taking you you're
emotionally like I'll do it out on me
I'm sorry you weren't hugged as a child
there I have things and I enjoy things
why are you hiding so much on your own
show that's what I want to thank I was a
therapist
this is a very guarded set that you have
all of this stuff do you need to prove
to people that you're that loved that
they send you all these dolls yes yeah
but I I got it I got a commercial break
here against a break up against the
commercial break god Leah I'd love to
spend the best way to defuse when
somebody's coming at you what do you do
that because you're insecure yes yes I
am I'm all of these above absolutely hey
Congrats on the film and love the
mustache looked hot and you know we both
have one thing in common we both made
out with Marissa Tomei
well there you go you know and I felt
that warmth during this this interview
and yours was in a movie big thank you
bill
all right that's bill burr the movie is
king of Staten Island